well people looking for storage units
may be paying more than they expect one
man says his price has recently gone up
even more Joe Mueller is live near
Sahara and Sammy Davis Jr Drive with
more Joe
well it seems like just about everything
is going up some people are noticing
increases on the prices that they are
paying for their storage units an expert
we talked to says the best thing you can
do to get the best rate is to shop
around about ready to start affording an
apartment at this point it's getting
that expensive for it I mean it's just
plywood Andrew Levitt says he almost
pays 700 for two storage units it's a
trend many are noticing when looking for
a unit it's more than they expect
according to move.org a storage unit can
run 100 to 300 depending on size Sherry
Sutton is an expert on storage unit
facilities she says the demand drives
the prices the street rates have gone up
nationally operators have been able to
raise their street rates and still
maintain their occupancy she says as
more people work from home and buy new
furniture they're looking for places to
store items she also says more people
move during the pandemic and there was
an increased need
now back out here live Sutton says that
the best thing you can do is look around
and look in several areas around town if
you happen to look in one area that has
more facilities in the in the let's say
the one block or two you could be paying
less reporting live Joe Moeller live
local now